scissoring is a real thing
three two one
you're like that's not what you do
scissoring it's not what you think
[Music]
I have fallen for a straight best friend
depending on who watches this I mean
okay depending on who watches this this
person might already know or might not
know um you can't help who you fall in
love with I think that's clear we all
know that we already have attractions
that was my problem was knowing but not
being able to tell anyone or doing
anything about it so like literally
going home every night crying and like
why am I like this how can I change but
especially growing up in a small town
where there's really no queer people so
who you really only going to fall in
love with straight people I think when I
was younger I was like obsessed with my
best friends specifically like girl best
friends where I wouldn't say I was like
in love but I placed a lot of like the
love feelings that I wanted on them
without knowing what it was it never
happened even like long long ago I I was
always dating girls who were not
straight if I had found out that someone
I was interested in was straight I'd be
like that's it I had a lot of
internalized homophobia um and all my
friends were always queer growing up
since like elementary school so for me I
think I never gave myself that
opportunity to like fall for a straight
girl basically a lot of my women best
friends are queer or ended up coming out
I've lost a lot of friends for coming
out because it's like oh like the Kaylee
She's a Lesbian she likes me no that's
not how it is my very attractive best
friends that are just my friends and are
like this you know and that's just how I
am
scissoring is a real thing
three two one
wow I'm shocked can you say porn yeah
okay
but no some people especially you know
maybe CIS men that fetishize lesbians
will see porn and they're doing things
that like you don't do like that's not
something you do um but it is real and I
mean it's validating people that do it
but it's also like it's not what you
really think
it's not what you think
you see it to believe
we've all we've I've done it so I
believe that it is real
I will take everyone's word for it
whatever you say Obviously
um I I don't
I don't know I've heard that it kind of
works and then I've also heard that
absolutely not they just won't do it it
does not happen I feel like if you enjoy
it it's real you like kissing it's real
you like scissoring it's real I'm saying
like there's no like rule book of like
how to be intimate with someone it's
your connection with your partner or the
person you're messing with
I'm gonna switch because
I've personally only been with two
people being queer my first experience
with the first person was very much like
I didn't know what I was you know what
to do or what to expect it personally
didn't do much for me that's why I
wanted to switch because I do know it's
real because I have done it but just not
my thing I certainly think it's real I
certainly think it's not for everybody
but I also certainly think it's a trial
and error like you have to practice
basically and keep going I'm gonna I'm
gonna turn into a Sex Therapy
like it's you have to do what sorry
everybody's body type is different
meaning every angle
angle so that's what I mean by trial and
error and you really have to do it
multiple times until you get it right
it's like everything you do stuff until
you learn what you like so I have never
had sex with a man
damn it
there's no middle ground
yes or no
kind of we have some gold stars
I've only been with one man who just so
happened to be trans that was enough for
me to be like this is not me I was still
seeking the parts of him that I think
connected him to Womanhood and I really
did him uh disservice like I was a
terrible person for that also the whole
thing with gold stars I just
I I feel it's not great gold stars
should should not mean anything in my
opinion because yeah or like what do you
mean I mean no agree I wasn't saying
that like oh congrats to us because
there are lesbians who are like oh I
will only date like people gold stars
I'm not saying like gold stars are
better than not it's just a term in my
mind that's what I was like referring to
when I said that not like I disagree
with the whole thing of gold star
lesbians being better than yeah everyone
else
yeah no it happened you know
it was I was in high school you know you
live and you learn you tried I tried
tried multiple times and I was like
something ain't clicking like isn't that
supposed to be amazing and then had it
with women I was like oh got it funny
that you said that because I I feel like
the first time I had sex was the first
time I had sex with a woman I came out
when I was 29 and I was about to be
engaged to a man and so I was at the
point where I had to be real with myself
and really have had to be like if I
don't come out now I'm going to be 50
with a child and married
um coming out I have had sex with men
um I was straight for 29 years
um but I always knew I was gay
um but yeah so that's why I'm here with
the wide spectrum of what people
consider Sexes I had my fair share of
experiments with men I had thought I was
asexual because I didn't have any
romantic attraction to men I felt forced
to engage in certain activities these to
fit in with my friends my CIS friends
around me it just happens and if you're
not growing up with homosexuality being
normalized you're kind of just forced
into it
I dated men through college I still
don't consider myself like full on the
Kinsey scale or whatever fully fully
lesbian I'm still attracted to men but I
was super Christian and so I just was
not doing sexy things at all which is a
bummer I like wish I would have had sex
with men that's gone now ring on the
finger I'm moving forward I don't know
sounds like it's not all cracked up to
be from over there I don't know yeah
like a part of me yeah like I genuinely
do agree because like I grew up like
also I was very like Christian household
and like you know when I was younger I
thought like you had to wait till your
married have sex and then when I
realized that's not a thing I just was
like oh I really just don't like men
what do I do and then I just like pushed
it aside all that stuff so I mean there
is a part of me that's like wow I'm like
I really will never have sex with a man
so I don't know yeah I don't think
there's anything wrong with having sex
with men but yeah maybe in a maybe in
another world I in another life I will I
don't know not this life I guess
I just I've been like a tomboy like my
whole life and like I've always viewed
like my guy friends it's my guy friends
and like I didn't know that like in
elementary like one of my guy best
friends had a massive crush on me
because I was like oh that's the problem
yeah like I've just always had friends
and it's never been more than that it's
it's a little silly that like I'm
standing on this line and Imagining the
comments already of people being like
well how do you know that you're lesbian
if you didn't try it with a guy they can
shut up and I'm like they can shut up
yeah it's like well I would never ask a
straight person that yeah yeah exactly
it's the same thing like you don't go to
Street people being like well you've
never had sex well
I mean I always tell people to try it if
they want but I mean I'm a bad influence
I feel like women being on the queer
Spectrum at all is like less legitimate
to some people than like men saying that
they're on the queer Spectrum at all a
lot of people refer to me or other women
in my life is like it's a phase so
you'll get over it it's a phase but like
I don't really see that happening with
men if they're gay or whatever it's
everyone's like they're gay which I
think is a privilege it is like in a way
a privilege because you already
established I'm a gay man like I can't
even tell you how many times I've been
with my partner my partner and like oh
that's your friend by my own parents oh
how your friend doing
you've seen us holding hands what do you
mean how's my friend doing you know I
don't do this with my friends unrelated
but the amount of times I've like
visibly kissed my partner on the lips in
public and then had somebody come up to
me like you're really close with your
sister
and I'm like excuse me
um
uh so yeah I do under like that is
always really weird for me um but that
was it was a little unrelated but it
does happen a lot I think that we all
have our own struggles
um I've known people where it's like oh
I'll show my I'll tell my kids about
lesbians but not gay men like they can't
see that because
for a lot of men they they fetishize
lesbians in a way so it's less it's more
approachable for them gay men they're
like oh no like you know like the F slur
all that stuff like very aggressive
towards them so I feel as if it is
easier to come out as a lesbian to some
people based on societies like
fetishizers and stuff it's funny because
it would probably be the opposite I'm
Mexican and my dad one time we would
like go to rent movies and one time he
got Brokeback Mountain without knowing
what it was about he was like oh yeah
sometimes two men fall in love and then
when I came out to him it was like the
most disgusting thing to him uh for my
culture and my experience it's a little
bit different because a woman being with
another woman and like a man not being
present is kind of just fed into like
the machismo in my culture so that's why
I would strongly agree lesbianism has
always been not only fetishized but
romanticized people get to Cherry pick
what part of queer culture they want CIS
women kissing each other at parties and
oh that's so cool that's so hahaha
quirky in a sense of hate and hate crime
you're a lot more to take a double take
at two men holding hands than you are
two women holding hands because are they
besties or are they a couple you know
you never know I have damaged
relationships with my loved ones because
of my sexuality
I feel like my relationship like with my
parents has kind of shifted it since I
came out I have no regrets like my
parents love me for like who I am and
even though they're a little hesitant
like you know I have one of my guy best
friends are you sure you don't want to
date Sean like he's so nice for you I'm
like they don't get us they're still
that disconnect because I do wish they
reacted a little bit better to it but
there's nothing I could do about it at
the end of the day I still love who I am
and I'm not going to change myself for
even my parents I grew up severely
Mormon and my relationship with my
father is non-existent because of it and
I am a firm believer it's because he
chose the religion over me the only
thing he said was read this verse in the
Bible there was no conversation or
nothing
it still hurts obviously because he's
still my father but if he's not gonna
love me a hundred percent don't love me
at all and that's how I see it
similar to you I had kind of a rocky
relationship with my dad he was very
angry when I came out and now he's at a
place where he has told me like I accept
that you're gay and I accept that you're
going to be with a woman he's like I
just had a vision of what your life was
going to pan out to be and and you kind
of just threw that off he tells me he
accepts me but it's just gonna take time
for him to acclimate to being around my
partner my dad is also like terminally
ill so I rather not carry like anger
through the remainder of years that he
has left with him and just kind of like
acknowledged that at least he's he's
trying to make an effort to love me for
me I also haven't I haven't spoken to my
father uh this year remarked five years
and when I came out as trans my
attraction to women uh my father had a
problem with it at that point I guess it
confused him and to this day that is an
expectation that trans women should are
only attracted to men and that's not the
case I'll say now I miss my dad
I love him
I tried
it's done I feel bad it's like everyone
has such like a heart I was I always
been very blessed
um my family's very accepting they've
always they've always knew so when I
came out they're like okay very lucky
I feel so bad saying that after that I'm
like
yeah
I'm like I'm gonna stay quiet
you found your parents which is what a
lot of people don't have and hopefully
you're gonna carry that onto your kids
if he does that happening
but hopefully like you'll get to share
that with other people so don't feel bad
I mean it's a good thing we're happy for
you
I'm like it's a bliss yeah definitely
definitely
this is a wrap we all did amazing it's
so good give yourself a round of
applause
[Music]
[Applause]